>>Male Speaker: So, good afternoon everyone.
I am extremely thrilled, extremely excited
to welcome Humphrey Slocombe to Talks at Google
today.
Humphrey Slocombe—
[applause and cheers]
Yes, yeah.
They even brought us ice cream, how awesome
is that?
[cheers and applause]
>>Sean: Oh wow a bigger cheer for the ice
cream than us, come on.
[laughter]
>>Male Speaker: So for those of you that may
be tuning in on YouTube, Humphrey Slocombe
is a bit of a San Francisco tradition.
They're an icon, a humble ice cream store
on 24th and Harrison in the mission.
They constantly push the boundaries of ice
cream as a desert and as a way of life.
And today we have joining us the two folks
behind it.
We have Jake Godby and Sean Vahey.
And they created the icon.
They're fame has spread nationally.
They're here actually now to talk about their
book, appropriately titled "The Humphrey Slocombe
Ice Cream Book".
So without further ado, we'll go ahead and
talk a little bit about the book.
Talk about ice cream making.
We'll have time for your questions at the
end, we'll have the Q and A mic over there.
So please join me in welcoming Jake and Sean
to Google.
[applause]
>>Jake: Thanks for having us.
>>Male Speaker: So, the first thing I wanted
to start out with was the book itself.
What was your inspiration, your idea for making
it?
How did it come about?
>>Sean: Well we were actually approached to
do the book initially 'cause it wasn't even
on our radar.
>>Jake: No, we had a couple different publishers
approach us about doing a book.
You know at the time we were only like a year
old.
And it's like, why?
And we still felt like such newbies at the
game, so.
>>Sean: And then it took us an additional
year to write it, so we were two years in
by the time it came out.
>>Jake: Yeah.
>>Male Speaker: Cool, cool.
And it seems to me like going through the
book and like reading about your story as
to how you two met.
You know formed the business and everything.
It's a story very similar to that of Grant
Achatz and Nick Kokonas over at Alinea's in
Chicago.
You know one person's doing the flavors, you
know advancing the craft there.
And then one person's handling the business.
So Jake, what I wanted to know, how did you
decide to specialize in ice cream from your
prior pastry training
>>Jake: Well to be honest I thought we could
open up an ice cream shop with less people
than it would take to open up like a bakery
per se.
'Cause when we opened it was just Sean and
I.
I made a, we both scooped it, or we both scooped
it and we were working 20 hours a day, working
our asses off.
If we did something else, it would be more
of a production that we didn't, was just not
possible.
And, yeah.
>>Sean: By ourselves sucked.
>>Jake: Yeah.
>>Sean: It was terrible, I mean we literally
worked all day.
You made ice cream all night while I drank.
[laughter]
>>Sean: We tried to deal with it.
>>Male Speaker: And you had that champagne
party where you got your first employee.
>>Sean: We did—
>>Jake: Oh yeah.
>>Sean: That's actually an interesting story.
We, when we had kind of a thank you party
for our friends and our family and we had
so much help.
And during the party, we were like, "We're
gonna hire somebody from this party who's
helping us portion and pan."
And the deal was whoever kept my glass full
the entire party is who we'd hire.
[laughter]
>>Sean: Despite what their background was.
And enter Emily.
>>Jake: And she stayed for three years.
>>Sean: And she stayed for three years.
She could pour a mean glass of champagne.
[laughter]
>>Male Speaker: That's nice.
And Sean, so how was the transition to managing
the ice cream front from your prior experience
in the restaurant business.
>>Sean: It was really weird.
Because I came from a background of Hyatt
and Four Seasons.
So I kind of thought I knew everything.
And I didn't know anything.
You know there, nothing prepared me for what
Humphrey Slocombe brought us.
You know, we're still learning a lot.
So, you think you know something but you know
nothing.
>>Jake: Well I think a lot of our success
comes from his fine dining, or both of our
fine dining background.
Because we tried to create the same experience
in our little ice cream shop that you would
get at a nicer restaurant.
>>Sean: Yeah
>>Jake: The same level of customer service.
>>Sean: That's right.
I mean customer service I would say is, it's
kind of the same across the board.
No matter if you're like super rich or if
you're just like us.
Poor.
[laughter]
And everyone wants the same good customer
service.
So it doesn't matter if you're up Four Seasons
or Humphrey Slocombe, you still want to be
treated well.
And that really interpreted well across the
board.
But everything else, forget it.
You gotta learn how to run a business and
like fast.
So.
>>Male Speaker: And then, and then also another
key component of your success is your massive
Twitter following.
And the hundreds of thousands.
>>Sean: Yeah.
>>Male Speaker: And you described it as—
>>Sean: Were still getting used to that.
We still don't know how it happened, right?
I mean, we knew we had a great product.
And we knew that we wanted people to come
to our area of the Mission.
So we turn to Twitter.
>>Jake: We had no advertising budget.
>>Sean: Yeah, it was like $-1000.
[laughter]
>>Sean: So when we turned Twitter on, we we're
like, "What is this [censored]".
It was so boring, it was like, [high pitched
voice] "I'm gonna go to the mall”.
[laughter]
>>Sean: And we were like what?
So we made our Twitters really dirty.
And like, really naughty.
And we were just like, we just wanted people
to pay attention to us so that it would, they'd
eventually come to the store.
So it got us in a lot of trouble, but it also
got us the attention that we wanted.
>>Jake: Yeah.
I've had it described to me that we're like
the sassy gay friend of the twittersphere.
[laughter]
>>Jake: I love that.
I had never heard that.
But yeah.
And then as we started getting more people,
you know we toned it down a little bit.
So I think we found a nice balance.
And if you're not following us, follow us.
>>Male Speaker: @Humphrey Slocombe.
And likewise you grew like a rabid fan base,
but also some haters that you mention in the
book.
>>Sean: Oh yeah.
>>Male Speaker: You describe them as your
frenemies.
>>Sean: Well that.
Yeah that was like the harshest reality.
It was like, you know we're, we're generating
a lot of attention through the direction we
decided to go which was naughty.
So then with all the people that kind of love
the, the spirit of it.
There's also people that are like all right,
if you guys want to be, you know, this sassy
I'm gonna take you on.
And we had some pretty harsh haters.
>>Jake: Yeah, we've had a parody as well.
>>Sean: And death threats.
>>Jake: And death threats.
And it just, there some crazy people out there.
>>Sean: You haven't lived until you got first
death threat, let me tell you.
[laughter]
>>Male Speaker: It's all that fetal kitten,
you know people just can't get behind it.
>>Sean: Yeah exactly.
>>Male Speaker: And you even include some
of the tweets and e-mails in the book.
And I thought that was pretty interesting.
>>Sean: Yeah, that was our publishers idea,
and we weren't sure how we were going to do
a.
Originally it was gonna be kind of like a
ticker line across the bottom.
But I'm glad we didn't do that because each
tweet kind of has its own personality I think.
And it's, they're fun to read separately.
So I think our publisher did a great job kind
of separating them.
>>Male Speaker: Did you have like this archive
of like really crazy e-mails to go on?
Or did you--
>>Sean: Oh my.
>>Jake: I wish we would've saved more.
Cause we didn't know the book was gonna happen
that way.
>>Sean: Yeah.
So there's so many good ones we last.
>>Sean: We had so many good ones, and the
ones that were like the scariest we decided
to post, like, on our freezers just so that
it wouldn't intimidate us like we wanted yo
owner.
>>Jake: We had to embrace it.
>>Sean: Yeah.
So like the really scary ones, like the death
threats, the ones that said people were gonna
kill us, we were just like all right let's
post them let's look at them every day and
lets like own it.
I wish we'd kept them.
>>Jake: I wish we had kept the erotic poetry
that one girl.
>>Sean: Oh yeah we had people drop off erotic
ice cream poetry.
>>Jake: Yeah.
>>Sean: Yeah.
>>Jake: Right
>>Sean: We've gotten all kinds of great e-mails.
>>Male Speaker: And you maintain that style
through the book to.
One thing that I really enjoyed was the same
irreverent style you present in the storefront
is also there in the writing.
So is that a conscious decision?
Did that just sort of—
>>Jake: Yeah, absolutely.
Come out of your pen as you were typing along?
>>Sean: Yeah, we, I think we wanted to just
kind of keep our voice.
And that was also the biggest struggle.
Because, you know, we understand that our
publisher wants to sell books and you know
we do to.
But we also, I mean we had to keep the cursing
down a lot.
>>Jake: I mean if there's anything that both
of us can't stand, we hate cute.
And it's so easy to go cute with an ice cream
book.
>>Sean: They snuck that picture of the kid
in our book.
[laughter]
>>Sean: We said that there could be a kid
in the book, but the kids gotta be crying
and their ice cream has to be on the floor.
>>Female audience member 1: Oh my god.
[laughter]
>>Sean: Like that's what we wanted.
>>Jake: There are much more pictures of trannies
than children in our book.
>>Sean: Yeah.
>>Jake: So we fought for that.
>>Male Speaker: And dentists apparently.
No dentist in the ice cream book except for
this one.
>>Sean: Yeah, I was like Jake you can't mention
you're a dentist in an ice cream book, like
that's gonna drive people away.
>>Jake: Nah.
>>Male Speaker: Right and just moving also
onto the ice cream making process.
You know in the book you describe the importance
of creating a base and then you go through
talking about several different bases.
So we have like the Philly style which is,
you know, without eggs.
We have like a sorbet, we have the full-bodied
cream.
Do certain bases work better with certain
flavors?
You know what was your approach for you know
choosing the different ones?
>>Sean: That's Jake.
I have spiders in my oven, so.
He's the--
>>Jake: [laughs]
Well I think for the Philly style which is
without eggs, I think that has a more natural
fit for cleaner flavors like a fruit flavor
like a strawberry because there's less fat
to mask the tongue.
And you just, it comes across more cleanly.
But the ones that have egg yolks are just
a more fuller richer fatty flavor.
>>Male Speaker: And then the sorbets, you
know, focus on the essence of the flavor itself.
>>Jake: Yeah, exactly.
>>Male Speaker: Standing alone.
And then, you know what about sorta nondairy
bases like soy, you know we've seen, almond
milk.
>>Jake: I don't know anything about that.
[chuckles]
>>Male Speaker: All right, we won't mention
any of that at all.
Froyo?
>>Jake: We are an ice cream shop.
>>Sean: Yeah.
>>Jake: People are asking about that and it's
like it says ice cream on the door.
[laughter]
>>Sean: We will never intentionally do a fat-free
or a sugar-free or.
>>Jake: Yeah, it's just, we only have 12 flavors
a day.
There's plenty of other places to go.
>>Male Speaker: And it was interesting actually
today in the cafés at Google, we rolled out
a salute to Humphrey Slocombe.
We had a bit of throwdown, I smackdown if
you will.
So we had all frozen yogurt.
We used to have ice cream, but we have since
moved in the froyo direction.
But we had some hibiscus beet, we had some
curry caramel. and then you know Secret Breakfast
was cool.
>>Jake: Nice, great.
>>Sean: So good.
>>Male Speaker: But yeah I think we need – –
>>Jake: I fully support people who join, doing
that sort of thing and having fun.
>>Male Speaker: And that's one of the points
you make in the book too, it's like you know
you need to change the flavors.
You know throw in more of one, less of another.
Like make it your own flavor instead of just
following the book.
>>Jake: I mean it's pretty cheap and easy
to make ice cream in a little ice cream machine
at home.
And if it doesn't work, you start over again.
>>Jake: And put your own personality into
it, you know, that's how Jake come up with
a lot of these.
And it's easy for you to do yourself.
>>Male Speaker: Cool, cool.
And so we do have some questions from the
Twitter base.
You know, they submitted using Google moderators.
So the first one that I have it from a Dan
H in the United Kingdom.
He wants to know what is your number one hands
down favorite piece of inspiration, that's
favorite with a U, you've had which led you
to create a flavor and what was it.
>>Sean: God, Michael Jackson?
>>Jake: Yeah, that's a good one.
>>Sean: Our biggest selling sorbet is Jesus
Juice.
And, I know
[laughter]
>>Sean: And it was Michael Jackson's passing
that inspired us.
>>Jake: There was a, we've done a lot of tribute
flavors over the years.
>>Sean: We do a lot of tribute flavors.
>>Jake: I think that might've been the first
one.
>>Sean: Yeah, my favorite was Golden Girls
though.
>>Jake: Yeah, yeah.
But yeah it's red wine and Coke sorbet in
tribute to Michael Jackson.
If you don't know, get the reference, you
can look, you can Google it.
>>Male Speaker: Exactly.
>>Jake: We probably can't mention the reference
here.
>>Male Speaker: So what was the Golden Girls
one?
I think I missed that one.
>>Sean: Oh my God; it was strawberry cheesecake.
>>Jake: Yeah when Rue McClanahan died, we
did a –
>>Sean: When Rue passed away.
>>Jake: We did a strawberry cheesecake.
>>Sean: It was so good.
>>Jake: Tribute flavor.
>>Sean: I may have eaten like half the batch.
>>Jake: It's not a Humphrey Slocombe flavor.
>>Sean: It's not typical us but I mean you
guys, I don't know if you guys remember Golden
Girls but.
>>Jake: They all sat around.
>>Sean: They always sat around the kitchen
table eating cheesecake.
>>Jake: I think my favorite inspiration story
is Secret Breakfast.
It was way before the shop even opened.
That was back in Ohio on a roadtrip with friends.
And I was thinking about what kind of flavors
I wanted to make with my friends.
And my friend Eric just out of his mouth came
Secret Breakfast.
And that just clicked with me.
And then I figured out what it would be.
>>Jake: And that's also the first flavor you
made me when we decided to get together and
do this.
And I remember eating it and, like, I was,
like, oh shit, like this is the beginning
of the end.
Like this is, it's the flavor that, like,
got us going.
>>Jake: Yeah.
>>Sean: Yeah.
>>Male Speaker: Cool, and along those lines
of the small batches we have a question from
Mark in New York.
He wants to know why you even produce in such
small batches?
And then he goes on to notice inconsistencies
in the flavor profiles when he gets a same
flavor from a different batch.
>>Sean: Good.
>>Male Speaker: So with salt and pepper and
like olive oil.
>>Sean: He should get a little inconsistency
'cause it's handmade.
>>Jake: Yeah, everything, well the small batch
thing is we didn't know we'd be so busy.
And I should have bought a larger machine.
[laughter]
>>Jake: But we work with what we have.
And you know what we work with is, or is as
organic as possible, local as possible things.
And if sometimes a batch of strawberries is
sweeter or more tart then another batch.
Sometimes the salt-and-pepper will steep a
little bit longer or it's a finer grain that
we've used.
And there's gonna be variances and I'm totally
okay with that.
>>Sean: I don't think we've ever been so much
that you're getting a completely different
flavor.
I mean, we taste the ice cream during the
entire process that it's made.
And you know we like it to be consistent but
you will get different nuances.
And you know a batch of strawberries that
will help deliver will be just intensely sweet
and another batch will be you know have a
little bit of a tartness.
You know, everything will be a little bit
different because of the fresh ingredients
that were using.
>>Male Speaker: Do you, do you get like feedback
and adjust more from the customers or is it
just more like you prescribing strawberry
should be tart, vanilla should not be ordinary.
>>Sean: Well, we'll bring back flavors because
our guests ask.
I mean, that happens a lot.
>>Jake: Sure.
>>Sean: Or if like a flavor is not super successful,
we won't put that back in rotation.
And then we also have flavors where the fruits
in season for like, just a couple weeks.
Like, our sweet summer corn is only in season
for a short amount of time.
And we try to get as much of that out there
as we can.
Yeah, we listen to our guest feedback.
Very intensely.
>>Male Speaker: Cool, and then along those
lines we have Kimberly from Illinois was wondering.
What's the most popular flavor beside Secret
Breakfast?
I mean, Secret Breakfast obviously runs away
on its own.
>>Jake: Coffee.
>>Sean: Coffee?
Yeah the Blue Bottle Vietnamese Coffee.
'Cause it goes so well with the Secret Breakfast.
The highest selling sorbet is Jesus Juice
for sure.
>>Male Speaker: And the Coffee is on every
day, or almost every day.
>>Jake: Yeah it's one of the three flavors
that never changes.
>>Sean: We keep Coffee, Secret Breakfast,
the Tahitian Vanilla and.
>>Jake: That's it.
>>Sean: We also have Balsamic for the sundae,
but it's not out.
>>Male Speaker: Cool.
And then, we have a person name Fennel in
Chicago.
Were there any flavors you thought would be
great but just didn't pan out in the marketplace?
And also what's the most savory ice cream
you've ever made?
>>Sean: We tried to make a tribute to Peter
Paul and Mary.
Called Puff the Magic Dragon.
That actually didn't even make it on.
[laughter]
>>Sean: It didn't even make it past the lab
phase because we were trying to incorporate
hemp oil into it.
[laughter]
>>Jake: Of, I had forgotten about that.
>>Sean: And we wanted to make it green.
>>Jake: Yeah, I think there was some spinach
in there.
>>Sean: It was a horrible.
>>Jake: Yeah, forgotten all about that.
>>Sean: And we had to make it pretty quickly
'cause it was like the next day.
So, that didn't even make it out.
But it was pretty bad.
>>Male Speaker: Actually I had spinach flavored
ice cream one time in the Google Café
>>Sean: Oh nice.
>>Male Speaker: It was surprisingly good it
sort of work.
Oh.
>>Sean: It sounds gross.
[laughter]
>>Male Speaker: So is there also like a master
calendar, you know, that there is gonna be
like some flavor rotation that, you know,
if you don't see it today within the next
three weeks it'll be back?
>>Jake: No.
>>Sean: We'll never, yeah, I mean we can't
promise that just because you know we can't
look that far out.
And you know we don't know if again I'm using
strawberries.
>>Jake: And I mean, well there's holiday flavors
that we know we're gonna have.
>>Sean: Oh yeah, that sort of thing.
>>Male Speaker: Like Rosemary's Baby and.
>>Jake: Yeah.
Or – –
[laughter]
>>Sean: Pumpkin five spice.
>>Jake: Five spiced pumpkin.
Or, I Have A Dreamsicle on Martin Luther King
Day.
>>Sean: Baracky Road's coming back for obvious
reasons.
>>Male Speaker: That' nice.
So the book itself was written towards the
perspective of the home chef.
You know you want more people to make ice
cream on their own.
You know use the machines that they have.
And so you designed it for no matter what
machine they make, so whether it's a Cuisinart
or a gerbil ball, as you mentioned.
What's one simple mistake or common pattern
that people fall into when they make ice cream
at home that they can avoid in the future?
>>Sean: That's a good question.
>>Jake: I don't, it's, for me personally I
think.
[laughter]
>>Jake: I'm not gonna say specifically for
ice cream but people are afraid of salt.
Usually.
And all of our ice cream has salt it.
I think it helps just make the flavors more
punchy.
And so.
>>Male Speaker: And you also talked about
the importance of making the bases and making
sure you get those right before you move on
to sort of the graduating towards more flavors.
>>Jake: Yeah, try a couple by the recipe first
and then when you feel comfortable enough
to play around, go for it.
>>Male Speaker: Yeah, focus on the fundamentals.
>>Jake: Yes.
>>Sean: That's right.
>>Male Speaker: So any advice on folding in
ingredients whether that's caramel or like
nuts or whatever.
That's one issue that I always had when I
make my own ice cream at my apartment.
I just couldn't get the fold right.
>>Jake: What were your issues?
>>Male Speaker: Well, I mean it seems like
I would put in the top and then I thought
I was in a Cold Stone I wasn't sure if I need
to dump it onto the marble slab or like do
it inside the machine.
>>Jake: Well I mean it's certainly up to you,
I mean if you wanted to be completely uniform
and try and mix it up as much possible.
But I like little pockets of, kind of like
clusters in mine.
>>Male Speaker: Oh cool.
And then of course your recipes are scalable
too.
So if you want to do like half a batch or
like a sample, it's doable?
>>Jake: Yeah, I mean they all make about a
quart so kind of difficult to do less than
that.
>>Sean: That's pretty standard for homemakers
right?
The quart?
>>Jake: Yeah.
>>Male Speaker: Cool.
And so looking at the wider world, it seems
like once you guys got started like other
groups popped up as well.
You mentioned in the book that you had this
dream of opening an ice cream truck.
And it seems like our friends in New York,
The Big Gay Ice Cream Truck.
They made it through.
They succeeded where you haven't got off the
ground yet.
Any jealousy there?
Or how did the relationships start with them?
>>Sean: Actually not really, cause they went
from truck to store.
And we originally looked at a truck and I
don't know.
>>Jake: They have different regulations for
food trucks in New York than we have.
>>Jake: It's pretty impossible to do an ice
cream truck.
>>Sean: They don't make their own ice cream
either.
We were required to have a place to make ice
cream and then take it on the truck by the
department, the dairy department.
So that's how we turned into a shop.
>>Male Speaker: Oh cool
>>Jake: So.
>>Sean: So basically if you make ice cream,
package it, put on the truck, you can sell
it fairly easily.
But if it's like us where you make the ice
cream and you want to scoop it on the truck,
there's a whole new set of guidelines which
is why you don't see a whole lot of ice cream
trucks in that style.
I don't know if you've noticed that.
But there aren't really, there's like one
that I know of.
Mike, thanks a lot.
>>Male Speaker: And if I remember, you all
created a pop-up restaurant to.
So how did that turn out?
Or will you be doing in the future?
It was so good.
>>Jake: Oh that's--
>>Sean: It's your pop-up.
>>Jake: Yeah.
I'm doing a little, it's a little side project
just to have something to do that's not ice
cream.
Just for another outlet.
And to have fun.
It's every three weeks.
>>Sean: It's called the Truckstop Café.
>>Male Speaker: It's also on Twitter.
>>Jake: It's a dirty divey little gay bar.
>>Male Speaker: Cool, cool.
And also the partnership extends to through
area restaurants.
You know, you supply ice cream to places like
Mission Street Food, Encanto, Flower + Water.
Are there any particular pairings that you're
most proud of?
And how do you approach the collaboration
with actual restaurants?
>>Sean: Wow we have so many we love everyone
that we work with.
I know, Jake, you know works closely with
a lot of the chefs.
And you know a lot of our relationships stem
from friendships.
You know just in the restaurant community
that Jake's had or I've had.
We love working with everyone.
It's hard to nail that down.
>>Jake: You know I mean it's different with
each restaurant because a lot of chefs want
to be involved in every single aspect.
And a lot of them just want nothing to do
with pastry and just want to let us help them
make decisions.
And we give it and it's a dialogue.
It's actually one of my favorite parts of
the job is just working with the chefs.
>>Male Speaker: And to what extent do you
have to work with the entire menu or does
the ice cream stand on its own?
>>Jake: Well the entire menu, not at all.
But some chefs will ask ideas about pairings.
What you think would go with this?
That sort of thing.
>>Male Speaker: And apparently, you mention
in the book, olive oil as being the next great
topping, right up there with hot fudge caramel
and the whole lot.
So I'm a little lost there.
>>Sean: It already kind is, I see olive oil
as an ice cream topping a lot.
>>Jake: Yeah, I think.
>>Sean: Ours is incorporated, we use McEvoy
which we think is the best olive oil on the
planet.
>>Jake: Yeah, it's always one of my flavor
suggestions for restaurants because it's a
nice alternative to vanilla in that it pairs
well with almost everything.
>>Male Speaker: And you can, like, you can
build it up with more flavors.
>>Jake: Yeah
>>Sean: Sure.
>>Male Speaker: Cool.
And so also I wanted to look a little bit
more towards the future to and so we do have
time for the audience Q&A.
So if you have questions sort of spinning
in your mind if you will you can actually
line up at the mic and then we'll get to them
as well.
You have a new project that you mention in
the book called The Parlor.
Can you tell us anything about that?
Like, how is that coming along?
[laughter]
>>Jake: It's like every business in San Francisco,
it takes a lot longer and a lot more money
than you initially think it's going to be.
And this opening up something even after opening
a business it's still extremely difficult.
It's going to be a bakery café.
>>Male Speaker: Oh OK.
>>Jake: Someday.
>>Male Speaker: Oh cool, so like still in
the Mission?
>>Jake: Oh yeah, yeah in the Mission.
>>Sean: Florida and 20.
So were close Portrero mission.
>>Male Speaker: Nice.
And then also, I was wondering as well, like
Humphrey Slocombe, is definitely ingrained
in San Francisco culture.
It's really a part of SF, it's in the Where
magazine, it sort of, the Food Network comes
by there to.
Do you ever see this tradition expanding beyond
the Bay Area?
We had one person, Aporvia who was clamoring
for one in San Diego.
So are we gonna see mail order Humphrey Slocombe.
>>Sean: We actually did mail ice cream for
a little while.
And it was a disaster.
[laughter]
>>Jake: Yeah.
>>Sean: It was so bad.
>>Jake: It's extremely expensive to ship ice
cream.
>>Sean: And it's, the timing has to be perfect.
And you can't mail more than what is it 5
pounds of dry ice and it takes 10.
>>Jake: And it was just embarrassing to tell
people how much it cost us for them to buy
like five pints of ice cream.
Because I.
>>Male Speaker: Need the dry ice.
>>Jake: Yeah and then it's like I felt like
they thought we were gouging them.
And really we were not making anything off
that.
It just went to FedEx.
>>Sean: It's hundreds of dollars to get 6
pints of ice cream.
>>Male Speaker: So you think you'll see flavors
in the pint at Whole Foods or the Package
Liquor Store or something like that?
>>Sean: We've been approached.
Yeah, people are asking us.
>>Jake: We're just a tiny little ice cream
shop right now, we have to figure out, we
have to have a larger production facility.
>>Male Speaker: Well that's part of its charm
to.
Like you know, you come to San Francisco it's
a destination.
You go to the Mission, experience the food
that's there.
>>Jake: It's still such a wonderful thing
to hear, because we are only three years old.
And.
>>Male Speaker: It's amazing.
So we have some audience Q&A, so you, sir.
>>Sean: sweet.
>>male #1: Hi, a quick question about the
upcoming foie gras brand.
What will happen to the ice cream sandwich
the foie gras ice cream sandwich?
>>Sean: That's a good question.
>>male #1: Can we have a week of only, everyday
or something?
[laughter]
>>Sean: We should have like a secret foie
password.
>>Jake: We're gonna start making it pretty
frequently from now on until what is it?
July, I think is the end.
>>Sean: July 5th
>>Jake: Yeah we're gonna have it available
a lot more until the very end.
>>male #1: Thanks.
>>Sean: Thank you.
>>Male Speaker: And you made a cheese ice
cream to that comes out every once in a while.
>>Jake: Yeah we made a Government Cheese ice
cream, not very often.
It's very expensive to make.
>>Sean: 'Cause we really don't use government
cheese.
>>Jake: We use like an expensive French cheese
called Mimolette.
>>Male Speaker: Yeah, no Velveeta equivalent?
>>Sean: Nope.
It looks like Velveeta.
>>Jake: Yeah it looks like Velveeta, the color
looks like Velveeta.
>>female #1: Hi.
>>Sean: Hi.
>>female #1: Have you guys ever thought about
making your own cones?
>>Sean: Oh yeah.
We, we did a lot of cone research.
That's a great question because it's a source
of frustration for both Jake and I.
Cause we love ice cream cones to.
>>Jake: Yeah, and they smell really good when
you go to a place that makes them.
>>Sean: Oh my God how great is that.
>>female #1: Yeah like Ici and Tara's in Berkeley,
they have amazing ice cream.
>>Sean: Oh my god, like Ici's cones are so
good right?
>>female #1: Yeah they're really good.
Is that something you guys are exploring.
>>Sean: Yeah we fully researched it, I mean
I think this is one of the things that we
did our due diligence on.
In many ways.
Because we do love cones and we went through
how many different kinds?
>>Jake: I don't know.
>>Sean: Like a million
>>Jake: But we're sort of small.
The shop is tiny and we can barely keep up
with making the ice cream.
And we get 1000 people a day on the weekends
so I just can't see how we could be able to.
>>Sean: And we go through almost as many cones.
And it keeps the price down which is great.
And you can always get a cone with your scoop.
Like I love getting a scoop of ice cream with
cone on top.
And I call it with a hat.
And you know that way we're able to give that
as an amenity away whereas if we made them
you know it would be a little more costly.
>>female #1: I think you could probably charge
additional for cones.
I know Ici does that.
>>Sean: No absolutely.
>>female #1: And so that would help maybe
balance economic of it to.
>>Sean: Yeah, we were gonna go down that road.
I mean we, the chefs are already standing
shoulder to shoulder in the kitchen.
I feel so bad.
>>female #1: Alright, awesome thanks.
>>Sean: Alright thank you.
>>Male Speaker: Well I'm a dish myself, so
I've never had to cross the cone question.
>>Jake: I'm a dish person as well, you have
to eat it too fast on the cone.
>>Male Speaker: Yeah exactly.
>>Sean: I'm a dish and cone.
Like why not both worlds right?
[laughter]
>>Sean: Get it all.
Hi.
>>female #2: Hi, thank you for coming.
>>Sean: Thanks for having us.
>>female #2: Yeah, in your book, you mention
if you're using, if you're gonna go with a
coffee flavor we recommend Blue Bottle.
Or if you're using, you know, this kind of
milk we recommend this brand.
That's very helpful, thank you.
But for someone that's trying to experiment
on their own, how do you recommend, like how
many times do you guys typically try a certain
brand of chocolate before you move onto the
next one?
Or can you talk a little bit more about that
experimentation.
>>Sean: That's a good question for Jake.
>>Jake: Interesting, I mean I've been cooking
for a long time so I have, like, my favorites.
And we use Recchiuti chocolate at the shop
because it's fairly local and it's delicious.
And it's a little bit more, we started out
using Valrhona.
>>Sean: Which is so expensive.
>>Jake: Yeah, it's a little bit more cost
effective.
I, we use products from our friends.
>>Sean: Yeah.
I would say, just like for me cause I don't
cook at all.
Like at all.
[laughter]
>>Sean: I would just start off with what your
favorite things are.
You know like if you have an awesome coffee
that you think rocks your world like use that
for the coffee.
We love Blue Bottle because we drink it 20
times a day.
And we love them as a company.
And I think, we think they do a great job.
But if you have a coffee that you're in love
with, use that, like why not.
Make it your own.
>>female #2: All right, I'll bring you some
Hula Pie coffee from Hawaii.
>>Sean: Done, that would be great, thank you.
>>Male Speaker: And you also get you know
these ideas for your fans as well like the
salted licorice girl if I'm not mistaken.
>>Sean: I feel so bad.
>>Male Speaker: If you're watching the video,
come back.
>>Sean: Salted licorice girl I'm so sorry.
We, I love black licorice.
And we make a salted black licorice ice cream
which is just mind blowingly good.
And we, this is when we first started, it
was just Jake and I.
And, was I just in a bad mood?
>>Jake: Well, we were cranky.
>>Sean: I was so over it.
We may have even slept in the store that night
like making ice cream all night.
And then we opened up and I was just like
please someone stab me in the face.
[laughter]
>>Sean: Like, I'm just done.
And this girl who I'd made this connection
of salted licorice ice cream with came in
after coming back from like where did she
go?
She was like in Sweden.
She brought back these chocolates, and I didn't
recognize her right away and I was like can
I help you?
And she was just like, her eyes got really
big and she just threw the licorice at me.
And I was like, what the hell just happened?
And then it hit, automatically click.
So licorice girl, I'm so sorry.
[laughter]
>>Jake: I know, it's difficult because we
see 1000 people a day and they only see the
two of us.
>>Sean: Yeah, it takes us a minute to register.
That's I think one of our biggest restrictions
'cause we meet so many people and were so
happy that people are coming in.
And that they want to say hi to us.
But like it takes a second.
We need like face recognition software.
>>Jake: Yeah.
Can you guys work on that first?
[laughter]
>>Jake: It's like our little private joke,
and it's like we'll be nice to meet you and
they'll be nice to see you again.
[laughter]
>>Jake: Yeah
>>Sean: We're like wuh wuh.
>>Jake: Ouch
>>Sean: It's tough.
But salted licorice girl, I'm looking for
you.
>>Male Speaker: And then you had some other
crazy guests come in as well.
I remember Ferran Adria stopped by one day.
>>Sean: Oh my god.
>>Male Speaker: So what was that like?
>>Jake: That was huge.
>>Sean: So humbling.
>>Male Speaker: Like one of everything I think.
>>Jake: I mean, he's a culinary rockstar.
And you know he did have one of everything,
he stayed for like an hour and hung out.
And had his picture taken with everyone in
the shop.
>>Sean: And he's the quote on the back your
books.
>>Jake: Yeah, and it's just like he travels
with an entourage and his chain-smoking interpreter.
>>Sean: And that's what we want, we want an
entourage and a chain-smoking interpreter.
[laughter]
>>Jake: It was surreal.
Yeah.
>>Sean: Sure.
>>Male Speaker: And so what you think to like
you know with Ferran and the molecular gastronomy.
We have different ways of making ice cream,
too, so there's a place in SF that does the
liquid nitrogen-based ice cream.
Like how does that sort of fit in your worldview
with.
I mean, you got exotic flavors, traditional
methods.
They got some more ordinary flavors, exotic
>>Sean: We love it, we love Robin.
She's great.
And what a great idea.
You know.
>>Jake: Yeah it's fun.
>>Sean: I mean Jake and I have always said,
especially in San Francisco there is room
for everybody.
>>Jake: Room for everyone.
>>Sean: And if you set up 20 more ice cream
places, like there's room.
So go, I think everyone should get as creative
as possible.
And go crazy.
Because it's ice cream, like who doesn't want
ice cream?
>>Jake: Yeah.
>>Male Speaker: Cool, cool.
So I wanted to close by saying, one part of
Google culture that I liked which I think
really blends in with your thoughts in the
book.
So we have a program called culinary internships.
So for those in the audience that haven't
done it yet, you got to do it.
You go into the café for a morning, you can
spin out some ice cream or froyo.
And it was really one of the pivotal experiences
of my time at Google was making ice cream
in the café.
>>Sean: Nice.
And anybody can do that?
>>Male speaker: Yeah pretty much.
Like you just sign up and you can do different
things too.
So we had one of our chefs was closing down
the café and so he had whole animal week.
And so it culminated with us, as interns,
making the bacon implosion.
Which was like everything a burrito is except
all the parts are made from bacon.
>>Sean: Nice
>>Male speaker: And then baked in the oven.
>>Sean: Yum.
>>Male speaker: So that was like the craziest
thing I made.
But we do normal things.
We did some Calvados caramel ice cream which
was like an alcoholic candy apple.
>>Sean: Excellent.
>>Jake: Yum
>>Male Speaker: It's good stuff.
>>Sean: That's a great idea.
So yes.
>>Jake: It must be a fun place to work.
>>Male Speaker: Well, you're welcome to stop
by anytime, we had Humphrey Slocombe today.
But we need to.
>>Jake: Can I have an application?
[laughter]
>>Male Speaker: Continue those google dot
com slash jobs.
Way to go.
Well, if that's the case.
I wanted to thank you both for stopping by.
The book, as I said is available in stores
right now, it's the Humphrey Slocombe, ice
cream book.
Amazing read, use it to revolutionize your
ice cream at home.
Thank you for stopping by.
>>Sean: Thank you guys, thank you.
[applause]
>>Sean: Wow.